[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHET HAASE: Hi, I'm Chet Haase,
an engineer on the
Android team at Google.
Recently, at Google I/O 2013,
we gave a talk called "A
Moving Experience," which was
about various animation
techniques and capabilities
of the Android platform.
And a lot of these techniques
centered around some of the
principles of animation
that early cartoon
animators came up with.
And I wanted to talk about a
couple of those briefly today.
One is anticipation, and the
other is overshooting or
follow-through.
And these techniques, along
with a host of other
techniques, are used
to help the users--
in their case, the viewers
of these cartoons--
very quickly understand what
was going on on the screen.
They had very few frames to work
with, sometimes 24 frames
a second, or actually more like
12 frames a second, maybe
even six or eight
frames a second.
So there wasn't a lot of time,
in any particular second, to
understand the action.
I mean, the actions would
happen really quickly.
And they needed the users to be
locked on to the action in
the cartoon constantly.
Because if they missed
it, it was gone.
And they didn't have
time to rewind and
see what had happened.
So instead, they gave as many
indications and aides to the
user as possible, to the viewer
as possible, so that
they could really clue into
what was going on.
Well, we have the same problems,
to some extent, in
user interfaces, where you
really need the users to
understand what's going on
in your application.
If many confusing things are
happening, if you're replacing
entire screens with entire other
screens, if the workflow
is really complicated as you go
from activity to activity
or screen to screen or view to
view, then how is the user
supposed to not get lost
in your application?
What you really want them to do
is be completely locked in
to the flow that you imagine for
your application, so that
they understand that flow as
well as you did when you wrote
that incredibly complex UI.
Well, if you can use some of the
techniques that they came
up with cartoons, then maybe
you can help the users
understand the interaction that
they're having with your
application, as well, and help
them understand and be more
productive with your application
at the same time.
So it's sometimes a little bit
of a stretch between these
cartoony effects and maybe the
effects that you're looking
for in your application.
But it is possible to connect
these dots and say, given this
technique, what they were
going for, how could we
actually apply that technique if
maybe not make it quite as
cartoony in the business
context.
Anyway, let's see
the actual demo.
So we have a demo here
called LiveButton.
If you click the button,
the button interacts.
So there's a couple
of different
interesting elements to this.
One is the anticipation, where
when you click on the button,
it gets smaller.
And when you release the button,
it doesn't just return
to its previous state,
but it overshoots
that and swings back.
So this is the anticipation
as it presses in.
And then it's the overshoot as
it actually comes back, not
just to its original position,
[? but actually ?] past it.
There are some interesting
aspects to this.
One is that it makes
the object feel
more organic and natural.
And it also makes them more
engaging, in general.
I saw techniques specifically
like this on a game
console, years ago.
And whether the buttons were
pressed in when you clicked on
them or actually popped out
when you clicked on them,
actually that interaction
didn't matter.
What I noticed was that the
buttons themselves were much
more engaging.
And this was really important in
the game context, where you
really want the whole experience
to be more fun and
engaging to begin with.
And it helps the user feel
like they're really
interacting with the machine and
the game, instead of just
clicking buttons in
a user interface.
So the way to get these effects
is very simple.
We'll see some more complex
applications of these
techniques in the other demos.
But in this particular
application, it's very simple.
I'm not actually handling
click events here.
All I'm doing is tracking up
and down events, and then
making the button look
differently.
I'm letting the [? superclass ?]
actually track the clicks and
the motion events, because I
don't care about that.
All I care about is make the
button smaller and make the
button larger to overshoot.
So we make it smaller by
grabbing a View Property
Animator on the button.
So we say,
clickMeButton.animate.
We set the interpolator to this
decelerator, which is a
decelerate interpolator
that we defined above.
This means that we're going to
start fast when they click on
it, and then slow down
toward the end.
And it's important
to start fast.
Because you don't want them to
hit the button and then get
this sluggish feeling as it
accelerates into an animation.
Instead, you want it to start
really quickly and possibly
slow down at the end.
But the main element you want is
actually two-- you want it
to start really quickly, and you
want it to be a very short
duration, as well.
So we use a decelerator here.
And notice that I actually
changed the duration of the
View Property Animator to 200
instead of this default 300.
Because I wanted the animation
to be very quick.
So we set the decelerator.
And then we simply scale
the button .
So we're going to animate that
scale, make the button
smaller, as the user
presses on it.
And then when they release,
we're just going to do the
same thing in reverse.
We're going to set scaleX
and scaleY, animate
those back to one.
Except instead of just animating
them back to where
they started, we're going
to use this overshoot
interpolator that we
defined above.
So it will actually animate past
one and then back to give
that organic feeling of actually
bouncing back out and
then finally settling into
its final position.
Anticipation and overshoot
or follow-through--
very important elements of
cartoon animation, applicable
to some cases of user
interfaces, if you want the
interface to be more indicative
to the user of
actually what's happening in
the flow, or simply more
engaging and playful
and organic.
Thanks.